joining me today is a friend a mentor a
living legend and a man who needs no
introduction the king himself that's
what it says right there hi Wow Larry
King thank you Dave was great to be with
you I was with you before you join this
network you were we've done this a
couple times that's what once in a weird
place where did you do that that was
well that doesn't was kind of weirds
lost weird love we did this once the
first time you did my radio show many
years ago in the Waldorf Astoria Hotel
right when you started aura yeah we
looked yeah in New York that was our
first time together then we did that
weird loft the Waldorf Astoria the night
of my senior prom High School prom was
the night of the OJ Simpson car chase
and I was at the Waldorf Astoria haven't
my senior prom I'm pretty sure you
probably know where you were at that
broadcasts near the car chase
yeah from Washington with maps of LA and
O's incredible yeah do you like that
kind of stuff more than everything I
like all of communicating I like
interviewing sports people I like
politics
I like entertainment I like the whole
ball of wax I like I like doing movies I
like acting I like making people laugh I
like touring I think what I love most is
communicating I've been curious all my
life
curiosity runs me I'm not the kind of
person you want to sit next to on an
airplane I'm just I'm pretty sure that
people would be happy to sit next no I
Drive - I Drive nuts yeah you think that
start with yeah Wow sitting next no no I
flew from New York to LA with the
president of OD all right and he sat
down old Larry came so proud to meet you
I knew after an hour he started going to
the men's room frequently eating his
food slowly and looking the other way
napping faking naps but I learned more
about cars than you could ever imagine
yeah things I was insatiable so that's
the way I am to learn about anything he
could have been a graphic designer an
accountant a plumber I'm just fascinated
where do you think that comes from
because really I know that from you
you're like a sponge you don't know
I remember being a kid I tell some of my
earliest memories ten years old go to a
Dodger game with friends if it's filled
Brooklyn New York
yeah players coming out of the dressing
room at the end of the game my friends
want autographs I never want their
autographs
I would ask questions why'd you bunt
yeah what happened there in the third
inning why'd you take that picture
running down the street I'd get on a bus
and Eska bus driver why do you wanna
drive a bus and that continued with me
and so what I took was this insatiable
curiosity into a profession that warmed
to it yeah the art of interviewing and
now I do a master class in interviewing
we've got tapes going out I just love
the whole concept of this yeah I like
asking questions like good I like being
asked yeah so I like the hope I love the
idea of coming I don't text I know I'm a
verbal person I've seen you dictate your
tweets so I know what's going to dictate
them I don't type them yeah but I like
speaking do you feel freer now that
you're doing that you do some of this
stuff too because I sense that in the
last couple years you're a little freer
with your own personal opinion my my
whole career was based on we just have a
contest in Miami what who does Larry
easier than our Democrat yeah because
I've always had the respect of both
sides I've never had a political guest
turned me down but yeah I you know I'm
82 years old and so I've never actually
said who I've ever voted for mm-hmm
but I'll give opinions on on issues as
they come up yeah whether they be
independent Republican Democrat but I
will voice an opinion on issues I have
strong feelings I always had strong
feelings in the air prejudice I when I
went down in Miami to break into
broadcasting I took a train down to live
with my uncle while I look for a job and
first thing I saw was a colored water
fountain I'd never seen that and so I
drank out of the colored fountain
instead of the white fountain I sat in
the back of the bus
and the bus driver stopped and asked me
to move to the front of the bus because
the back was for Negroes Wow
and I said My father was Negro and
stainless so I've always been big on
segregate and that I always was yeah but
on other issues now if you you know if
I've have an opinion on issue I'll give
it could you believe it I mean with like
in segregation in the South could you
believe like it seems so obvious to you
I try to explain it to my kids at 17 I
have older kids but my 17 year old and
16 year old sons I went with them to the
movie 42 mm-hmm
the Jackie Robinson movie and you know
they were looking at this wait a minute
he he was booed just cause he was black
you know try to comprehend that that I
live through all that
sasame car theism segregation and the
idiocy the idiocy of segregation I mean
the other stupid of getting example of
it Ross Perot gave this to me the
economic stupidity of segregation in the
south when they built an office building
or a high school they had to build two
bathrooms hmm two women's bathrooms two
male but on his floor much bigger
plumbing costs yeah
they segregated blacks in certain
schools whites in certain schools their
education system from blacks was poorer
so when the blacks got older how are
they gonna buy Buicks
so you know a gonna no economic sense
right so to hold any people down makes
no economic sense yeah so even if you're
not doing it at the human level just the
economic level you would think people
would hear that Hitler's idiocy he threw
out of Europe or killed or threw out the
Jewish community which was first
Germanic and then Jewish so he threw out
Einstein yeah he threw out great
scientists leaders fashion who enhance
your community so whatever you diffuse
any part of a community is it's insane
like on religion or color
would you be against someone because
that color what that's crazy yeah I mean
it's crazy you know it's funny I can see
it in you like that it legitimately
seems crazy to you I'll get a bus
example yeah total craziness yeah I'm
interviewing Ray Charles the wonderful
blind great singer yeah he thought you
were black no no Ray Charles was in
Florida grew up in Florida and he's in
high school it's a segregated high
school blind kids they're all blind
weight within a segregated blind high
school right they put it at White's on
one side blacks on the other side so he
knew he was sitting next to a black
because the white was on the other side
Wow I mean that's really is that crazy
it's just crazy all right so all that
being said it seems like we're in a
crazy political time right now but I'm
pretty sure you you'd argue that the arc
of this thing has been pretty good right
like actually we're in a much better
state people as Les Moonves said it
CBS loves this yeah they may not love
Trump but they're making a lot of money
off Trump because what Trump has
provided is the kind of thing on the
screen you can't turn off I don't know
what it is I mean I have no Trump for
years he's been on my show a hundred
times yeah I talk to him all the time
yeah with friends he was very nice when
I had my surgery New York he took my
wife out to dinner he was always very
nice to me very accommodating and I see
this now I look at him yeah and I
realized that now in this different
setting when he stands up there with his
speeches a lot of time half hour saying
nothing if I was saying how well he's
doing
yeah but I'm fixated mm-hmm fixated and
he you know you look back he destroys
some of these candidates and one he
destroys Jeb Bush just low-energy
he pointed to him said low-energy and
then every time he saw Jeb you said
Louis yeah
little Marco Rubio Marco Rubio yeah lion
crew
and he just gets on it and no matter
what you say it doesn't matter no matter
what he says I've never seen a political
figure like this yes so as an
interviewer when you've interviewed him
and and granted most usually it was
before he was running I think you did
you did do an interview with him a
couple months ago right as he started
how do you please on again this week oh
right so then I'm gonna hold you to this
answer whatever you're gonna tell me
right now how do you pin someone down
that is so good at not saying you try as
but she can because he'll he takes you a
question and doesn't answer it
yeah goes off into another area I mean I
asked them in the interview a little
while back what I if I do say so myself
was a pretty good question and I'll tell
how he handled it yeah Donald supposing
someone came up to you and said mr.
Trump I'm 45 years ago I'm 45 years old
I'm an illegal immigrant I came here 25
years ago picked grapes and now I'm the
foreman of that agriculture company we
have thousands of employees I asked the
answer to me my son is a basketball
stars in Notre Dame High School and my
daughter is a harpist she's a junior at
the same high school my wife teaches
school at UCLA want to send me back how
would you answer him Donald and what'd
he give you I I'd have to think about it
I'll let you know so I'll let you know
oh wait you don't know what you say no
I'd have to think about it it's a good
point yeah I'd have to think about it so
in a weird way are we run is there two
things happening in the country there's
sort of the people that care about the
issues right whatever they may be you
care about foreign policy or you care
about minority rights or whatever and
then there's this other thing happening
this sort of cultural candidacy and
that's what he's really hitting on he's
hitting on people that are just tired
angry of political correctness tired of
not being able to say anything so it so
he just is keenly aware that it doesn't
matter
he says right I mean is that really
what's happening here and on the other
side Sanders yeah who is totally issue
driven yeah everything has an opinion at
the direct kind of thing he's also has
that appeal yeah to that intelligent
young person or the revolutionary and
they both would probably if they work if
they had an opponent if Sanders had a
Republican moderate or Trump had a
democratic moderate they would both lose
yeah interesting but but Trump and
Sanders have about captured forty
percent of population each yeah what do
you make a Bernie so I know the style
job burned you have you don't wanna lose
a mayor of the city in Vermont
yeah as Jackie Mason said every Jew
growing up in New York moves to Miami
Beach Bernie went to bed Bernie's very
smart he's always been the socialist
yeah he believes in socialism which is
most of what most countries believe in
most countries agree with Bernie mmm-hmm
as England the England believes would
only when England would support Bernie
right they believe in a social system
where health is entitled you're entitled
to health yeah so he has a following but
there's never been a politically like
you mentioned didn't have been a
political year like this where the
rational thinking moderate is gone yeah
Hillary who has an appeal to what is the
basic democratic base will probably win
she will probably win because she'll
Sanders can't catch her in the
Democratic situation the Sanders voters
had nowhere to go
they either sit home right or they can't
vote for Trump or Cruz they might vote
for Kasich do you think there's any
chance they'd vote for Trump just
because they want the system to be
exposed that's the thing was frauds hard
to figure but I don't think I'm the
problem he's gotten into I think his
women mmm-hmm he will he will not get
the woman's vote and more women vote
than men and he won't get the women's
vote the women's vote will be it'll be
the law I think the Democrats will get
the larger
woman's vote in history Wow if it's
Trump or either way probably right
either way even Stu and you know they're
2 to 5 in Vegas just says Democrats
versus Republicans you've got to put up
five dollars to win two in there if you
pick the Republicans you bet to you in
five huh that's tremendous favor
those are big guys from of Democrats a
favored big Wow
so what do you but you know a like you
know
pundits they the pundits have been wrong
all along the Trump wasn't gonna last
Bernie Sanders's yeah mine and it they
proved been proven wrong